the apocalypse is in eight days the only
chance we have to save our world is
there's a new season of the Umbrella
Academy on the way and after that
massive cliffhanger at the end of season
wine there is much to discuss so we're
gonna break down everything we can
expect from season two of this hit
Netflix show right now on the ketchup
the comic book series based on My
Chemical Romance frontman Gerard Way and
Gabriel Baz award-winning graphic novels
was certified fresh in its first season
developing a massive fan base and
racking up forty five million viewers
according to Netflix the ten episode
second season began filming in June of
last year and is due out on July 31st of
this year and according to showrunner
and executive producer Steve Blackmun's
Instagram the current pandemic has not
slowed them down gay sisters gay sisters
just a warning we are about to rain down
with a bunch of spoilers so that would
be a great time to grab an umbrella now
at the end of season one Vanya blew up
the moon and as pieces of it began
crashing down into Earth causing in
apocalypse a dysfunctional family of
Heroes was teleported to an unknown
point in space of time by number five to
try and prevent these events from
happening
and according to Netflix's official
synopsis for season two the tundra
scattered the siblings in time in and
around Dallas Texas over a three-year
period starting in 1960 now this
suggests as we see in the comics that
the assassination of JFK could play a
role in the upcoming season the synopsis
also revealed that their disruption of
the timeline apparently causes some sort
of nuclear doomsday so they'll be forced
to deal with that along with the
affirmation apocalypse not to mention
the trio Swedish assassins that are now
hunting them down good time get up we're
going we're save the world lose it all
and while we can look to the comics for
more answers on what might happen it's
worth noting that they did manage to
save the world from the moon explosion
in the comics so obviously the show is
not following all the same story
elements so far the biggest clue we have
came from the show's Instagram page
where the script for the season 2
premiere was revealed titled right back
where we started
however we're not sure if this means
revisiting scenes from season 1 going
back to where they began is
I'm fighting children or neither that
makes no sense
oh it would if you were smarter the core
cast of siblings is returning for season
two and they will be joined by some new
additions including Youssef Gatewood
playing a character named Raymond who is
described as a born leader with smarts
gravitas and confidence so funny that's
exactly what my horoscope said about me
this one ritu Arya will play Lila said
to be a chameleon with a twisted sense
of humor and Marin Ireland is playing
[ __ ] a fearless no-nonsense mom from
Texas none of these characters have
appeared in a comic so we're not sure
how they will factor in but they could
very well be a part of the 43 superpower
children born on the same day as the
Hargreaves kids in 1989 and due to the
frequency of flashbacks in the show and
the time-traveling there's a good chance
that their father Sir Reginald
Hargreaves and time-traveling assassins
hazel and cha-cha could return as well
and here's hoping we get to see more of
mary j blige we meet new people and then
kill them you have the best job alright
friends it's about that time to kick it
over to you now what do you want to see
in season two let us know all your
thoughts and feelings in a comment
section and for more binge guides and
streaming news head on over to Ryan
Tomatoes calm also don't forget to join
our fan group on Facebook we're staying
safe and staying fresh is honestly a way
of life my name is MJ uppity Co I live
in Chicago Illinois
stay safe stay fresh everyone and if you
don't want to miss out on any future
episodes of this show because why would
you hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always muchas
gracias for watching the catch up my
name is ass Prez and thank you so much
for watching this video again bye
[Music]
you